si vous êtes comme moi et que la cuisine
au barbecue vous fait peur le reportage
de notre journaliste Gilda menu avec ses
bons conseils de sécurité vous donnera
probablement envie de vous rapprocher de
votre grill donc quoi ne pas faire on
prend nos poitrine on les met à
on met nos poitrine encore plus à
nos fonds
de cette bonne marinade là parce qu'on
veut de la plante le feu cet élément
nécessaire à la cuisson fait rêver
l'amateur de barbecue mais attention la
flamme est l'ennemi des grillades
l'huile surtout les huiles végétales ils
vont brûler à très basse température sur
la grippe ça tombe en point de fumaison
puis en plus c'est une néfaste pour la
santé il faut qu'on veut clairement pas
sûr quand vous achetez une viande qui
marinée on vient vraiment l'essuyer
avant parce qu'il y a rien qui va donner
la saveur là-dedans après jetez-vous les
marinade sèches ou des bonnes épices là
même chose les épices c'est la base la
marinade sèche
la flamme peut être aussi un ennemi
dévastateur
sans une augmentation des incendies en
lien avec les barythus de type charbon
charbon de bois granule donc on demande
aux citoyens peut-être plus vigilants en
fait avec l'utilisation de ses appareils
un barbecue dégage beaucoup de chaleur
la combustion libère aussi du monoxyde
de carbone certaines précautions sont
donc de mise
où est-ce qu'on installe son barbecue
c'est quoi la première règle à suivre en
fait le barbecue on doit l'installer à
au moins 60 cm de toute ouverture du
bâtiment donc on parle de porte de
fenêtres on va aussi placer notre
barbecue loin des matières combustibles
pour s'assurer le qui est pas de début
d'incendie de cette façon là on ne doit
pas placer l'appareil dans les issues
dans nos sorties de secours on doit
garder les sorties dégagées
avant la première utilisation on verse
une eau savonneuse sur les branchements
de gaz si des bulles apparaissent c'est
qu'il y a une fuite il est temps de
changer le boyau et son régulateur
[Musique]
bien entendu si au niveau de l'entretien
ça va être très important donc si on
laisse tout le temps le restant droit le
sel les résidus on échappe un bout de
fromage on essaie de faire des frites
sur le barbecue il tombe au travers mais
c'est sûr que ça c'est toutes des
éléments qui peuvent être des
combustibles on veut pas que ça donne
des combustibles cependant les aliments
ne sont pas supposés dans un combustible
dans un barbecue fortune
c'est des vieux résidus qu'on ne veut
clairement pas dans notre barbecue donc
c'était le temps de le nettoyer
c'est que ce petit gros là qui est tombé
il y a pas brûlé tout de suite il est
revenu à l'état genre solide puis là
trois barbecues plus tard il redevient
un peu liquide puis là du gras en feu
c'est comme de l'huile sur le feu ça va
prendre un feu et puis ça va devenir
vraiment dangereux dès que vous voyez là
qui est un peu trop de résidus n'hésitez
pas à lever vos grilles gratuit
l'entretien de barbecue on veut des
grippe propre bien entendu pour le côté
santé si vous voulez avoir de quoi de
bon c'est pas avec le vieux créazade
puis la vieille saleté de quelques
années qu'on va le retrouver au début de
la saison il ne faut pas négliger
d'enlever les résidus qui s'accumulent
sur les diffuseurs de chaleur
ensuite il faut bien vérifier l'état des
brûleurs si on l'a pas bien nettoyé bah
il peut rester les résidus puis c'est
résidus là ben ils vont être corrosif
qu'est-ce qui arrive c'est qu'ils vont
faire rouiller vos brûleurs si les
petits trous sont toutes calculés par un
ingénieur pour être sûr que c'est la
bonne quantité de gaz versus d'âge qui
va sortir pour faire une belle flamme
mais si ces petits trous là sont tout
ouvert ben là on vient de doubler
tripler cadeau play la quantité de gaz
qui peut sortir puis on peut avoir des
flammes qui sont qui sont pas vraiment
efficaces non plus au niveau de la
chaleur
les araignées tissent leur toile dans
les tuyaux ce qui peut les bloquer et
empêcher le gaz de circuler
convenablement mais qu'est-ce que je
fais mais c'est super simple
[Musique]
un entretien s'impose aussi pour les
appareils au charbon
nous avons la grille de cuisson en
dessous vous avez une autre grille pour
le charbon de bois les sangles aux
autres qui tombent en dessous de cette
grille là ça vient tomber dans un bol
juste en dessous puis quand vous êtes là
vous la jetez pas dans les poubelles
premièrement ça c'est sûr
charbon de bois on va le disposer dans
un contenant métallique le truc c'est ça
c'est de la mettre dans un 60 dans
lequel vous allez le laisser là puis
généralement vous allez vider votre 60
dans toutes les mois ou les deux trois
mois
les particules peuvent demeurer la
incandes jusqu'à 72 heures
par exemple j'ai déjà vu 24 heures plus
tard le rallumer sans aucun problème ah
oui pas genre on ne souffle dessus
de façon sécuritaire on doit en disposer
et le garder éloigné du bâtiment
pour un barbecue à granules il est
important de laisser le système gérer
l'alimentation des granules et de vider
le contenant à cendre après chaque
utilisation peu importe le modèle de
barbecue vous allez allumer c'est à
couvercle ouvert ça c'est la première
chose ça sera au gaz propane aux
granules à charbon tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps
allumage au gaz la séquence normale ça
serait d'ouvrir notre bonbonne doucement
le gaz va remplir dans notre boyau on a
pas ouvert encore bien entendu on va
être sûr un certain que le gaz rentre
dans le tuyau pour avoir une pression on
allume les brûleurs 1 à la fois donc
vous avez un brûleur qui s'allume
automatiquement quand on tourne le
bouton ou que vous ayez un brûleur qui
laisse le gaz rentrer avec un petit
bouton là qu'on fait techniquement en
allumeur c'est un à la fois comme ça on
est vraiment en sécurité et si par
malheur vous avez un début d'incendie
on ferme le couvercle compose un enfant
un si vous êtes capable de fermer la
bouteille avec le propre à l'intérieur
vous pouvez le fermer c'est capable de
fermer le conduit de gaz naturel vous le
fermez et sinon vous ne vous aventurez
pas ne vous exposez pas à des blessures
inutiles composer le 911
selon la pièce à griller et son
assaisonnement il vaut mieux parfois
profiter d'une chaleur indirecte pour
éviter les flammes on comment bien faire
la bonne façon ou je l'utiliser sur la
grille du haut on va avoir un bon
résultat donc on a une cuisson qui va
être indirecte mais quand même assez
élevé on va avoir une bonne chaleur
c'est pour le poulet pour que ça cuit le
35400 je vais mettre mon brûleur au
maximum bah médium maximum gris duo que
la chaleur est radiante et
conventionnelle autrement dit donc ça
sera pas la grille qui va faire chauffer
mon poulet
[Musique]
ouvert je le mets en plein centre ici
donc oui je vais avoir de la chaleur
mais j'arrive pas trop de chaleur
j'aurais surtout pas de retour de feu
parce que si j'ai une flamme vivent en
tout ça le gars ils font ils tombent
là-dessus ça prend on veut pas en fait
c'est pas du tout le spectacle auquel on
s'attend c'est plutôt calme ouais c'est
un barbecueil et en contrôle on joue
avec le feu le feu ça se respecte la
viande et les aliments ça se respecte
aussi donc en mettant un contrôle de
tout je pense que c'est c'est la
meilleure façon de le faire